zu fällen es ist dienstagabend schön
dass sie eingeschaltet haben eine
kompetente gäste die
bundesschatzmeisterin der cdu
bundestagsabgeordnete und ehemalige
bundesministerin für ernährung und
landwirtschaft julia klöckner schön dass
sie da sind mit blick auf die aktuell
steigende inflation voller sie von der
bundesregierung schnelle wirksame
maßnahmen star gründung des und villach
stammgast hans ulrich jörges bewegt der
krieg in der ukraine er wird heute einen
ausblick auf ein mögliches ende des
krieges wagen sängerin julia neigel die
peter maffay im bild als nach wie vor
beste deutsche sängerin bedeutete udo
lindenberg bezeichnete sie gar als
außerirdische entscheidung mai gewinnt
heute die tänzer ist fabrik in grünheide
abrechnen schön dass sie da und
integrationsexperte ahmad mansour man
kann ihn auch eigentlich schon ein
stammgast bezeichnen wird über das
traurige und so wichtige thema der
ehrenmorde sprechen um mein name ist
lena schenke ich freue mich ihre
gastgeberin sein zu dürfen auch mich hat
heute etwas tief bewegt und zwar das
kona zeugnis der werbung um sie nicht zu
lange auf die folter zu spannen ja kaum
zu glauben herr lauterbach wird seinen
augen nicht getraut haben aber schweden
liegt weit vor deutschland und das
obwohl herr lauterbach doch mehrfach
behauptet hat dass deutschland im
europavergleich besonders früh durch die
pandemie gekommen sein diese theorie
spätestens jetzt widerlegt trotz der
strengen pandemie politik sind in
deutschland 2020 und 2021 pro 100000
einwohner 116 menschen mehr gestorben
als statistisch erwartet viel mehr als
bei fünf nachbarländer die früher
gelockert haben in dänemark der schweiz
frankreich österreich belgien und den
niederlanden gab es deutlich weniger
unerwartete todesfälle ebenso im anti
lockdown land schweben für lauterbach
eine bittere pille und für mich das
flammende signal dass die politik
während der korona panini endlich
aufgearbeitet werden muss die übliche
ausrede das konnte doch keine an reicht
längst nicht mehr aus
ich war gerade an israel und das hat
mich sehr überrascht und sehr
glücklich gemacht wie andere völker mit
dem thema umgehen diese sehnsucht nach
normalität diese drang einfach das leben
wieder herzustellen es etwas was sich in
deutschland vermisse und ich glaube das
hat auch sehr viel mit einer ganz großer
noko witt anhängerschaft die wir hier in
deutschland haben die einfach jenseits
von studios jenseits von maßnahmen
einfach diese normalität nicht mehr
haben will und corona es ein gute
gefundenen fressen dafür aber ich frage
mich warum wir nicht in der lage
sachlich und differenziert über das
thema zu sprechen und karl lauterbach
immer noch vom killer varianten spricht
und in der zukunft eigentlich sehr
pessimistisch blickt ja ich wage die
these dass die deutschen
todeszahlen auch damit zu tun haben
könnten dass bei uns gar nicht
unterschieden wird ob jemand an corona
oder mit corona gestorben ist und das
war absicht bei den corona politikern
das verschwimmen zu lassen wenn man
damit besser argumentieren kann ich
glaube dass andere länder das
auseinander sortiert haben hier war das
rk ii nicht dazu in der lage ist es bis
heute gar nicht und lauterbach
argumentiert ja immer mit den hohen
deutschen todeszahlen die so zustande
kommen um damit eine harte corona
politik fahren zu können ich muss jetzt
sagen man stößt ja jeden tag auf
irgendwas was ihnen eigentlich aus dem
amt hebeln müsste jetzt hat er ja seit
neuestem ein gesetzentwurf zunächst mal
vorgelegt über die triage meint dass bei
der einlieferung von ernsthaft
erkrankten menschen in kliniken
entschieden werden muss wenn es zu viel
auf einmal sind von den ärzten
entschieden werden muss wer wird
behandelt und wer nicht alle wer wird
zuerst mal hat über mehr danach
da gibt es da in diesem gesetzentwurf
gab es eine ex post triage das ist das
perverse was überhaupt je gehört habe
das hieße nämlich dass wenn patienten
eingeliefert werden die sozusagen
rettungs würdig sind andere patienten
die schon auf der intensivstation liegen
dort aus den betten geholt werden und
die nachgelieferten dort reingelegt
werden dass
erst mal vorgelegt und dann am selben
tag an der loburg er gezogen weil aus
dem verkehr gezogen weil er natürlich
wusste oder ahnte jemand hat es ihm
gesagt wenn du das vor der landtagswahl
in nrw noch dann
glaubt man muss natürlich ein sagen dass
das eines nicht aufgeht mit angst und
immer mehr horrorszenarien die menschen
zu domestizieren also ein einzug reichen
und dass alle jetzt hinterher laufen wir
alle wissen dass wir auf sicht gefahren
sind in der korona zeit ist wahr was
neues und natürlich jeder politiker egal
welcher partei
das unterstelle keinem etwas schlechtes
hatte vor so gut wie möglich dieses land
und die bürger durch diese krise zu
bekommen aber jetzt sind wir nach zwei
jahren viele haben die nase einfach voll
sie können auch nicht mehr auch
wirtschaftlich hat und da ich auch
wirtschaftspolitische sprecherin unserer
bundestagsfraktion bin weiß ich was die
folgen nach wie vor von corona sind und
das müssen wir auch abwägen und letzter
punkt dass er immer wieder von neuen
keller varianten spricht ich denke jetzt
mal am kinder an jugendliche auch mein
neffe hat in der korona zeit abitur
gemacht sie glauben doch nicht dass so
junge menschen das nachholen können was
sie sagt ihm habe ich den regen einzige
rückfrage eine frau körper ja das war
schon sehr oft und gerne ich auch auf
frei lauterbach ein aber die hauptzeit
der korona panini war's ja ihren sparen
von der union der der
gesundheitsminister war wenn man sich
jetzt die iw-studie anschaut und die
zahlen anschaut ist die union daran
interessiert die korona zeit
aufzuarbeiten und vielleicht auch mal zu
schauen was haben wir falsch gemacht die
schulschließung bei kindern sie haben
selber angesprochen wurde auch bei
anderen kindern was dazu geführt hat
wird es da von der union einen bericht
geben naja wir müssen 1 mal sind es gibt
nicht die korona zeigt corona hatte ganz
unterschiedliche phasen haben übrigens
corona auch mit uns als bevölkerung
gemacht hat am anfang große angst und
auch dankbarkeit dass die
bundesregierung damals war ich mitglied
der bundesregierung dass wir da auch
wirklich besser durch die anfangszeit
kam als zum beispiel in den usa oder
bergermann sie noch die bilder vor augen
die leichen aber bei aller jetzt doch
ganz so gut durch die zeit wie wir jetzt
auch 3 wir haben verschiedene zeit
phasen die die empörung über herr
lauterbach ist ja deshalb so da weil er
immer als kritiker aufgetreten ist als
derjenige der alles viel besser macht
und wir müssen ehrlich eingestehen auch
bei wissenschaftlern gibt es immer sehr
unterschiedliche meinungen deshalb
glaube ich muss politik ist aushalten
dass sie auch als berater
unterschiedliche meinungen hat nur dann
glaube ich kommt man auch raus aus
diesem kasten denken vielleicht von dem
was man hören will letzter punkt die
länder haben aber auch nicht glaube ich
ganz so gut mitgespielt kann da würde
ich gerne frau nagel plan was halten sie
denn von einem corona
untersuchungsausschuss den ich ehrlich
gesagt schon gerne sehen würde auch mit
blick auf die jahre der union ich halte
das für extrem wichtig ich glaube eben
nicht was sie gesagt haben dass alle
immer nur im besten sinne gehandelt
haben wenn man ein bisschen tiefer rein
blick sieht man zum beispiel dass es
gesetze gibt die zum beispiel den
bettenabbau gefördert und
subventionierter ins krankenhaus frau
struktur gesetz § 12 jedes bett bringt
einer klinik dass man abbau zwischen
6800 euro bis 12.000 euro das ist
richtig viel geld da haben kliniken den
fetten reibach gemacht das weiß die
regierung auch die in der sie war und
natürlich in der korona zeiten hätte man
schon zweiter die 16
gerade hatten 2021 wurden 60 klinik neu
gebaut oder ja nochmal aber die betten
abgebaut in den kliniken während der
korona zeit während wir erhalten
aufgebaut haben also da müssen wir
glaube ich als geisel sei es gab dann
bin ich gerne präzise im jahre 2021 hat
man ich glaube
60 kliniken geschlossen und im jahre
2020 ungefähr 30 ich bin wahrscheinlich
sogar darunter also das ist zb passiert
und dann gab es natürlich auch es hat ja
auch was eine personal zu tun dass ihr
sohn einig da ist nicht nur noch knapp
es ist auch ein anreiz für kliniken
einfach auf eine gewisse art und weise
geld zu machen die haben ja auch betten
einfach schlicht und ergreifend leer
stehen lassen geld kassiert ich sage
dass deswegen weil das natürlich auch
dinge die die regierung wusste weil das
krankenhaus fondsstruktur gesetz ist
seit 2016 existent und wird genutzt es
gab aber auch zum beispiel in einem
papier das nannte man dann auch panik
papier
vom innenministerium das wurde dann auch
gelegt da aber man das dann irgendwie
weiter gegeben hat dann gibt es nicht
mehr da ist nicht mehr dort da standen
natürlich müssen auch immer sie es
wollen sie die daten her wenn man muss
sagen es ist sehr schwer welt hat das
veröffentlich gewählt hat darüber
berichtet main auf das jahr hat mit dem
bettenabbau wir müssen natürlich schon
sehr emotional janthur gesetz § 12
einfach rein gucken ist ein gesetz gibt
es immer noch offiziell seit 2002 ist
sehr schwer zu erfassen dass die
bundesregierung wirklich extra betten
abgebaut hat also da würde ich jetzt
einfach das waren aber das gesetz ist ja
durch die politik geschaffen worden und
es wurde da auch ordentlich genutzt und
es gab halt eben wie gesagt noch
zusätzlich gab es noch diese
zusätzlichen pauschalen für die
intensivbetten die extra freigestellt
worden sind die zum teil leer standen
und aber trotzdem bezahlt worden ich
weiß nicht ganz genau wieder die
pauschale war zwischen 5.000 1000 euro
also das wissen andere besser aber die
gab ist eindeutig da haben also menschen
tatsächlich im hintergrund auch gesetze
genutzt und strukturen genutzt die sagen
wir mal
mit steuergeldern
deutschland der fall gewesen ist dass
menschen die auf die intensivstation
mussten nicht auf die intensivstation
konnten weil jemand betten nicht belegen
wollte ganz viel sagen denn das
erschleichen aber das sei so viele leute
sie durfte nicht operiert werden eine
herner in der theorie zu beweisen ich
glaube wir müssen jetzt ein bisschen
differenzieren auch schon es geht um die
intensivbetten sie haben eben die
intensivbetten genannt bei der
intensivbetten ging es darum ob
krankenhäuser überlastet waren also in
den regionen wo wir hohe corona
instanzen hatten oder eben nicht und das
in dieser zeit wo wir corona infektion
sehr infektiös in den kliniken hatten er
hat man nicht dringend notwendige
operationen zurückgestellt viele sind
auch selbst freiwillig davon
zurückgetreten weil sie nicht ins
krankenhaus wollten das ist auf dauer
ein problem im übrigen wenn man schaut
auf das thema krebs erkrankung apples
dazwischen fragen die sache mit der
gesundheits überlastung des
gesundheitssystems sie sind also immer
noch der meinung das gesundheitswesen
war überlastet
nein das
noch mal
draußen dann weiß das und deine sei man
so noch mal es gibt nicht das
gesundheitswesen ich glaube wir müssen
hier schon differenzierter reingehen ich
komme aus einer region rheinland pfalz
ich habe meine stadt bad kreuznach als
zwei kliniken wir haben aber auch
innerhalb dessen in kleineren städten
kliniken die waren ziemlich schnell
überlastet kann ich ihr sagen wenn in
einem dorf in einer großfamilie corona
ziemlich heftig zugeschlagen war diese
klinik dort das system dort überlasst
erst gab's aber schon immer ein thema
das intensiv station auf einzelnen
kliniken ausgelastet waren haben unseren
anteil des marktes werden irgendwann
war es auch richtig man wusste ja nicht
was auf uns zukommt was mich stört ist
diese eindimensionalität wir reden ja
seit zehn minuten über das virus aber
corona ist nicht nur das virus ist es
auch die maßnahmen und die
nebenwirkungen
die nachfolgend von von die lok downs
und die einstellungen die wir gehabt
haben ich habe wirklich angeschaut auf
lauterbach twitter in den letzten zwei
jahren und ich habe kein einziger
erwähnungen für die psychische folgen
auf die menschen diese studien gibt es
herr lauterbach sagte mal dass er nicht
sicher ist ob die zusammenhänge jeder
vierte erwachsene weiß gerade psychisch
auffällig die kinder
jugendliche die vor zwei jahren nicht
ihre normalität zurück bekommen haben
diese druck die kinder werden
verantwortlich auch für die erkrankung
von erwachsene das hat massive
psychische folgen die wir schon sehen
und es gibt diese entscheidungen nicht
bezüglich auf die körperliche versorgung
sondern auch psychischer versorgung
häuser mussten sie ein jahr warten in
berlin bisher in psychotherapie platz
haben kein einziges wort deshalb würde
ich gerne sehen dass wir mit dieser
alten politik brechen in der zeit in der
pause die wir jetzt haben
weggehen von diesen besessenen
gesundheitsminister der das muss ein
crooner nur der nur darauf wartet dass
es wieder losgeht mit einem killer virus
dass wir einen neuen gesundheitsminister
oder gesundheitsministerin kriegen wenn
ich so höre verklagt da könnte ich mir
vorstellen sie werden das in der cdu
geführten regierung ich sage jetzt
nichts und das bei der gleichen
gelegenheit auch der lka-chef wieder
ausgewechselt wird denn das lka hat
keine präzisen zahlen mehr seit geraumer
zeit wenn die nur noch geschätzt aber so
ausgewiesen als seien sie genau penibel
berechnet worden das sind sie nicht das
heißt deutschland tastet sich durch den
nebel und darauf ist ein minister der
schon das nächste virus beschwört und
damit muss eigentlich wenn wir sich die
die ukraine krise hätten müsste die
politik dieser bundesregierung jetzt
schauen und jetzt die gelegenheit
ergreifen
diese minister stuhl zu räumen und neu
zu besetzen und das rk ii neu zu
besetzen sofern wir das thema beenden
nach einer rückfrage an sie frau
plötzlich viele machen sich jetzt schon
wieder gedanken über den herbst sind
jetzt in der opposition nicht meine
regierung aber müssen wir uns gedanken
machen dass es im herbst wieder losgeht
mit lockdown maske tragen und so weiter
ich hoffe nicht ich eines müssen wir uns
glaube ich klar machen wir werden mit
dem virus leben und leben müssen und wir
müssen die schützen die besonders
anfällig sind und tages hat sie ja
vorhin auch angesprochen diese
unterscheidung mit corona oder an corona
gestorben zu sein
ich kenne fälle die haben heftigste
verläufe gehabt ganz heftig weil ich
kenne auch junge menschen die gestorben
sind zwei in meiner näheren umgebung
aber ich kenne ganz viele die es noch
nicht mal mitbekommen haben dass corona
hatten oder hat es ganz leicht hin wir
müssen damit leben und ich glaube was
ganz wichtig ist ein paar dinge die wir
ja auch wirklich geübt haben hygiene
spielt kann immer nicht schaden keine
frage und wer eine maske tragen will
soll eine tragen aber mein blick geht
richtung kinder geht richtung auf die
schule was wir diesen jungen menschen
was ist für uns ältere sind zwei jahre
ja ist ein bisschen nervig aber für
junge menschen in der entwicklungsphase
was das heißt was das auch an ich sage
immer schäden für das ganze leben mit
bringt das in relation zu setzen das ist
mir ganz wichtig alle daraus auch lernen
ich möchte auch daran erinnern was nicht
alle aber viele lehrer diesen kindern
angetan haben die lehrer und 40
argumentiert und ich für die kinder
absolut sie wollten in sicherheit seien
sie wollten zu hause bleiben sie wollten
masken vielleicht in der klasse haben
und was mit den kindern passiert ist war
ihm gleichgültig das ist eine hat von
beruflichem egoismus den man eigentlich
nicht ertragen kann und das schlimme ist
die kinder jetzt bewegt ja nicht nur die
korona maßnahmen sollen jetzt ist ja
auch der krieg in der ukraine und da
zwei sein team ja wir haben ja alle
gesehen die rede von wladimir putin am 9
mai bei der großen militärparade in
moskau er hat dort eine erstaunliche
moderator rede gehalten er hat keine
keine eskalation des krieges der ukraine
angekündigt und wenn man dorthin schaut
auf das schlachtfeld kann man
feststellen es gibt dort kaum mehr
bewegung also es sieht so aus als hätten
sich die beiden armeen erschöpft und als
gebe es eine art von takt auf dem
schlachtfeld das heißt jetzt ist es zeit
darüber nachzudenken wie kommt man aus
diesem krieg raus ich glaube dass keiner
der beiden in der lage ist in anderen zu
überwältigen jetzt gibt es in der
deutschen debatte die jetzt begonnen hat
zwei verschiedene thesen die erste sagt
oder arbeitet mit der formel die ukraine
muss siegen die fdp militärexperten
schlafzimmer man beispielsweise sagt
diesen satz immer wieder was verbirgt
sich dahinter muss genau hinhören und
wissen was damit gemeint ist gemeint ist
damit dass die russische armee aus der
ukraine rausgeworfen wird und zwar
vollständig so dass die ukraine in der
alten form wiederhergestellt wird
inklusive krim und inklusive rostock
eine das würde aber glaube ich in sehr
langen krieg erfordern wenn es überhaupt
möglich ist ich halte das für
illusorisch die zweite these lautet gibt
es zwei sätze die ukraine darf nicht
verlieren und putin darf nicht gewinnen
olaf scholz sagt beide sätze die sind
interessant da muss man drüber nach was
meint ja eigentlich damit wenn man wenn
der eine nicht verlieren und der andere
nicht gewinnen darf dann ist man
irgendwie inbetween ja das heißt man
muss eine lösung finden mit der beide
leben können und diese lösung lautet
teilung der ukraine und zwar ungefähr
entlang der fronten die jetzt fast
erreicht sind wenn die russische armee
in der ost ukraine weiter ein bisschen
vorangeht ist sie da angekommen dass sie
die ostukrainische vollständig in besitz
genommen hat und dann wäre der zeitpunkt
gekommen um einen waffenstillstand zu
schließen und eine dauerhafte regelung
zu finden die wunde besagen wenn man die
ukraine teilt die russen bekommen die
krim endgültig den land gürtel der
entlang von dort aus entlang am
asowschen meer mittendrin liegt mario
pohl bis nach russland führt und die ost
ukraine sogenannten don was bleibt
russisch umgekehrt ist die rest ukraine
oder sagen wir besser die west ukraine
der größte teil des landes bleibt
selbstständig wird garantiert in seiner
existenz von verschiedenen großmächten
darf in die eu eintreten allerdings
nicht in die nato wird neutralisiert und
ist damit dauerhaft lebensfähig diese
lösung
davon bin ich überzeugt will auch olaf
scholz hat sie im hinterkopf darüber
redet man jetzt nicht weil man dann
lange argumentieren müsste man muss nur
sehen wie sich die dinge militärische
entwickeln und dann kann man in der
entscheidenden minute sagen dahin muss
die sache laufen olaf scholz builders
deshalb weil er auch der überzeugung ist
dass man eine gesichtswahrende lösung
für putin finden muss sonst gibt es
keinen frieden und der nachteil dieser
lösung es
natürlich dass
das der aggressor belohnt wird das
erfreute macht das muss man klar sagen
auf der anderen seite ist es aus
heutiger sicht die einzige möglichkeit
um frieden zu erreichen
frau klöckner ist eine angst und frieden
ohne die gesichtswahrung putins
überhaupt wirklich jeden fall sagen mir
ist die gesichtswahrung von putin total
egal wenn du dann rauswerfen könnten war
ich dabei also auch mal
eben wirklich auch wenn er sein gesicht
dann verliert wer erstmal ist putin
unberechenbar und wer sagt uns denn wenn
er was wenn er das zugeworfen kriegt vor
die füße geworfen kriegt was er sich
nehmen wollte dass er dann ruhe hält bei
der krim hat er auch nicht ruhe gehalten
also ich bin da hoch skeptisch und
deshalb unterstütze ich sehr
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine damit
die ukraine sich verteidigen kann es
geht nicht um angriffs geht nicht um
angriffswaffen quasi dass die ukraine
sich irgendein land holt aber wir müssen
noch mal noch mal dass wir mal wieder
den klaren blick bekommen da ist ein
diktator
der für sich entscheidet mehr reichten
die grenzen meines landes nicht und ich
nehme mal was vom anderen raus aus dem
land das aussehen das ist kein
widerspruch
ja ja ich weiß was sie dollar sie wollen
russland besiegen auf dem schlachtfeld
aber naja was heißt musik ich meine es
auch unglaublich roßlau bereit mal sagt
er darf nicht segen oder die anderen
dürfen mit sägen noch mal wir haben
einem zustand wo sich jemand etwas was
überhaupt nicht was nicht dem
völkerrecht entspricht was wir
sind ja auch fake news also die
behauptung er sein nahezu angegriffen
worden russland und all diese
geschichten ich glaube putin kein wort
egal was man mit ihm auch vereinbart
deshalb sage ich sehr klar wir sehen
dass das was putin sich vorgenommen hat
was er glaubt als würde er noch empfange
wohl jubel kaum zu träumen ja aber er
dachte er würde ja noch bio empfangen
werden als große erlöser das ist nicht
aufgegangen und er sät er auch und das
kostet auch ressourcen russlands und auf
dem grund sag ich sehe uns stets
überhaupt mit zwei jahre ist glaube ich
uns stets nicht so der ukraine zu sagen
oder einen präsidenten salzgebers mal
auf das gibt dir jetzt
vollkommen tsunami-warnung ski und
entschuldige mich das anwenden darf
dagegen selensky und putin waren ja bei
den verhandlungen der türkei schon fast
so weit dass zu vereinbaren also
seelands gehört auch gesehen er muss was
geben damit der krieg aufhört das ist
gescheitert wahrscheinlich weil es zu
früh also putin hatte sich noch nicht
genug geholt jetzt kommen wir in der
situation wo er sich auch angesichts der
schwäche seiner armee mit irgendwas
zufrieden geben muss bevor er ganz leer
ausgeht ganz leer geht aber nicht nach
hause wir haben die wahl zwischen einem
sehr langen krieg oder einem krieg der
die ukraine im kern land stabilisiert in
den westen führt in die eu integriert
oder einem dauerhaften krieg der das
land total zerstört mit einem russland
im hintergrund dass immer noch so stark
ist dass ich es für unbesiegbar halte
auch wenn die armee war es gibt aber
noch eine dimension die dürfen wir nicht
vergessen und die dimension sagt
wie können wir als europäer als
wertegemeinschaft auch abschreckend
wirken in der zukunft es geht nicht nur
um die ukraine ich bin jemand der kriege
erlebt und ich weiß dass kriege enden
müssen dass es ganz viel
schreckliches passiert für die menschen
die diese krieg erleben wir sitzen ja
hier in unserer friedlichen ort und
diskutieren darüber aber wenn wir wollen
dass solche taten nicht
nachahmer haben und wir haben ja in der
welt ganz viele diktaturen die auch mit
dieser idee spielen und diese fantasien
haben das lohnt sich nicht und da
mussten wir stärker zeigen und stärker
bedeutet waffenlieferung stärker
bedeutet aggression lohnt sich nicht
aber ich glaube damit muss und wie das
gerät verloren einmal ganz groß auf der
position und ich bevor wir weiter
blockieren glauben sie putin wie stehen
sie dazu
also ich bin ein bisschen zerrissen
innerlich ich bin grundsätzlich der
auffassung dass waffenlieferungen nicht
gut sind wir sollten uns eigentlich eher
aus der rüstungsindustrie komplett
zurückziehen ich habe das schon vor vier
fünf jahren gesagt von wegen die die
rüstungsindustrie
hochfahren wie dass die nato von uns
erwartet hat ich war komplett dagegen
ich bin einer der erstunterzeichner die
gesagt haben keine rüstungsindustrie
hochfahren es gibt natürlich auch
statements auch aus ihrer parteien der
ist zum beispiel um sich rückschlüsse
exporte bezüglich des jemen geht
geworden sagt auf keinen fall rüstung
oder waffen liefern wollen kein geriet
und dort die fis muss ist kommt man wenn
man ein ziemlich gut lassen sie mich
kurz ich bin ich bin sicher pazifistin
und ich will auch nicht zusehen wenn
irgendwo irgendwann krieg stattfindet
aber es ist wie gesagt keine lösung aus
meiner sicht wenn man noch massive
waffen in das land rein bringt ich halte
deeskalation politik und friedenspolitik
und alle parteien an einen tisch am
besten noch mit dem uno-generalsekretär
für die glücklicheren lösung ja es
finden wir das finde ich sehr wichtig
aber es war ja auch nicht so dass ich
teil war ja damals genannt werden möchte
ich hätte den brief von alice schwarzer
niemals unterschrieben ich auch ich
halte den verein kapitulation babbel
hätte ich niemals gemacht ich glaube man
muss entgegen drin ich hätte ihren brief
unterschrieben sind die hand die haben
den antwortbrief und da ich bin für
waffenlieferungen und auch von schweren
waffen und zwar nicht nur altes gerät
wie das aus deutschland jetzt an liefern
sondern modernes gerät mit dem die auch
sofort umgehen können denn was die die
bundesregierung tut ist doch ehrlich
gesagt ist doch eine schande also diesen
alten gepard panzer der nicht mehr
fahrbereit ist und für den es keine
munition mehr gibt der oligarch und
sogar für den tier am ort ja natürlich
ja natürlich also entschuldigung aber
auch aber frieden aber auch ihren start
camilleri ah da arbeiten wir auch
britische sage doch ich sage doch das
meine ich damit wir nähern uns einem
zustand wo putin vielleicht einsieht
dass er nicht weiterkommt mit der
aggression weil die ukraine wieder steht
weiter kommt er nicht als unten diesen
landstreifen und die krim zu halten und
die ost ukraine die überwiegend russisch
spricht russisch orientiert ist das hat
ja angela merkel mit dem minsker
abkommen versucht innerhalb der ukraine
zu lösen sehr kompliziert ein autonomer
status innerhalb der kanal ist nicht
funktionieren dürfen eigentlich
vergessen dass frauen eigentlich gerade
mit ihrer position erfasst
das kann ich nachvollziehen dass wir das
nämlich nicht so pauschal nicht erst
bringen sich dazwischen werfen so wie
ich wahrgenommen haben sie
bauchschmerzen damit ich glaube also ich
als parlamentarierin die zugestimmt hat
waffen zu liefern ich mache mir damit
auch nicht einfach genauso wenig wie die
kolleginnen und kollegen das ist nichts
banales mit sagen wir schicken mal was
ich singe aber sie trafen sind selten
einfach nur zum spielen da ist ich mache
einen ganz klaren unterschied ob jemand
jemanden angreift oder ob jemand
angegriffen wird und seine kinder seine
leute verteilen wir da werden menschen
vergewaltigt dann werden menschen
bevölkerung foltert aber inzwischen
sehen sich auch neun jahren gehört aus
wenigen ländern stark nochmal geräten
über die ukraine wir sind hier in
sicherheit ja wir sind hier in
sicherheit und sagen der ukraine also es
mit dem waffenlieferung finden wir nicht
gut die haben keine andere chance gerade
ich kenne es zynisch also freiheiten
unterschieden das level wort zu dem
thema es gab vor vier jahren gab es
die statistik das glaube ich die
bundesrepublik deutschland viertgrösster
waffenexporteur der welt war richtig ich
glaube jetzt ist er nummer eins oder
nummer zwei also mit dem 100 milliarden
das ist praktisch durch die decke ich
erinnere an den waffenstillstands
vertrag mit den alliierten der vielen
vielen jahrzehnten gemacht wurde aus
einem ganz guten wichtigen grund und wir
haben uns als staatsgebilde als
demokratie dem frieden verpflichtet wir
würden das normalerweise auch tun wenn
das nicht die ukraine näher ich sage bis
jetzt ist es ja immer so gewesen dass
man gesagt hat ihn jemand passiert
irgendwas da passiert was dort passiert
was wir wollen frieden frieden frieden
frieden jetzt plötzlich schreien alle
nach waffenlieferungen okay
waren afghanistan was ich auch gut fand
auch da sozusagen und werte unseres
landes auch zu kämpfen wir haben auch
uns beteiligt an kriege und ich glaube
das ist sehr sehr utopisch zu glauben
dass frieden einfach so existiert was
man nicht was anzubieten es gibt aber es
gibt nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
verschiedene verträge die man
miteinander gemacht hat unter anderen
der zivilpakt 1 unter anderem artikel 20
in artikel 20 heißt es darf keine
kriegspropaganda gemacht werden es
dürfen keine keine ja sage aber keine
propaganda in dieser richtung gemacht
werden es dürfen keine und deutschland 1
1 und kriegspropaganda grundsätzlich
sollte man sich aus allem heraushalten
das hat eine historie und ich persönlich
bin ich bin bestimmt nicht die einzige
aber hier in dieser runde ich bin der
auffassung wir brauchen die eskalation
und friedenspolitik und zwar die die wir
in den 90ern gekannt haben und die wir
in den 80ern gekannt haben und davor
schon 1 1 und jugendlichen als letzte
wort denn neben krone und neben dem
ukrainer krieg beschäftigt uns auch die
inflation sei einerseits film nine und
russland entscheidungen welche lösung
sie finden und niemand an kehl steht
aushält so reizen um innerhalb
der eu möglich wenn man jemand anderen
nicht das letzte wort über lässt sich
verteidiger und darin kommen wir jetzt
sofort klöckner und der inflation ja die
preise explodieren sie gehen richtig
durch die decke tag für tag also jetzt
nicht mehr nur punktuell sondern in der
breite wird das leben teurer
und wir haben eine inflation
ist die größte die höchste seit 40
jahren das ist alarmierend warum weil
wir merken es an der zapfsäule für
marken es beim wöchentlichen einkauf im
supermarkt
man mag das bei den heizkosten und das
ist ein problem für die breite masse
aber vor allen dingen für diejenigen die
den schmalen geldbeutel haben deshalb
hilft es auch nichts wenn jetzt so
kleine
stellschrauben wenn daran jetzt
gearbeitet werde durch die
bundesregierung an rentner und studenten
zum beispiel noch raus fallen soll eine
entlastung sondern wir brauchen jetzt
eine entlassung dass mehr in der tasche
bleibt also der staat muss von steuern
und abgaben zb bei energie bei mobilität
muss er runter um es günstiger zu machen
zweiter punkt ist die kalte progression
ist ein fachbegriff aber wenn jemand
eine gehaltserhöhung recht wofür jetzt
gekämpft dass man es sich auch wieder
was kaufen kann jeder nimmt der stadt
und gleich wieder mit und man muss sagen
herr lindner als finanzminister verdient
mit jedem inflationsfront
wo die inflation hoch zehn milliarden
euro nimmt er mehr ein und deshalb
brauchen wir eine entlastung jetzt die
also ich stimme im prinzip zu aber ich
habe trotzdem ein paar andere fragen
über die nicht öffentlich diskutiert
wird sie kommen gebürtig aus einer
winzerfamilie in rheinland pfalz wir
haben vorher darüber geredet zu welchen
preisen winzer wein vom hof verkaufen da
gibt es noch weißweine tja ich habe auch
einen abschluss gemacht dass china sich
nicht länger der winter verkauft
weißwein noch unter fünf euro die
flasche aber im restaurant ist das zeug
inzwischen tschuldigung schweineteuer
geworden weil da wird die preise erhöht
obwohl das zum gleichen preis kauft ich
will damit sagen gibt es nicht eine
entwicklung und zwar in der ganzen
breite des marktes dass alle möglichen
leute die gelegenheit beim schopf
ergreifen ihre preise zu erhöhen weil
sie ja quasi entschuldigt sind die
energie und der krieg und was da alles
rein kommt und
und die und die vorleistungen und die
zerrissenen lieferketten und alles macht
alles teurer und sie stecken sich die
taschen voll muss die neue technik auch
drei frauen also wer jetzt richtig gut
verdient da bin ich bei uns sind
übrigens
konzerne sind diejenigen die jetzt auch
calculator rüstungskonzern und jetzt
jetzt auch aber da dürfen warum jetzt ja
auch klar aber wenn wir uns das mal ganz
konkret anschauen zum beispiel die
glasindustrie
sie bauen unglaublich viel energie für
für ihre produktion eben zum beispiel im
fränkischen wo wir auch einen gürtel von
glasindustrie haben die schließen gar
nicht die tür auf weil sie jeden tag
drauf legen wenn das die preise sind
auch ihre preise nach oben das glauben
wir haben richtige lief aber warum
erhöht da wirbt er den preis der den die
flasche weißwein zum selben preis vom
winter bekommt den preis für die flasche
wein in seinem restaurant um einen
viertel liter
die
kolossalen er hat aber auch höhere
energiepreise jetzt sage ich mal den
winzer recht du kannst auch erhöhen zum
teil sind die wind die deutschen
weißweine erst kenner es auch schon
ausgezeichnet worden
die noch sehr sehr günstig die deutschen
weißweine aber wir müssen klar sagen
auch für landwirte wird es so
unglaublich teuer nicht nur dünn hat
nicht nur zur unterhaltung auch
futtermittel und vieles vieles andere
auch wir sehen zum beispiel dass die
getreidepreise explodieren wir werden
eine schlechte ernte haben die ukraine
ist galt als die kornkammer europas
jetzt macht die bundesregierung 1 sie
nutzt nicht die guten ackerflächen was
die eu kommission erlaubt hat was selten
genug ist dass die so genannten
ökologischen vorrangflächen jetzt für
nahrungsmittel produktion genutzt werden
können und diese bundesregierung
verzichtet darauf das ist zynisch
gegenüber allen anderen ländern die
hungern ich hatte heute wie eine
afrikanische delegation da gaben
nachfragen die können das 0 nachfolger
haben sie uns genau was sie damit machen
was ich damit meinte ist ein fakt also
es geht mir dass meine es ist es geht es
am ende darum es gibt in deutschland
oder in der eu ökologische
vorrangflächen das heißt die sind für
die biodiversität sie dürfen darauf
nichts anbauen auch nicht allein setra
haben fragt ihn rettet sich die letzte
biene so
dass wir uns verstehen ich halte das für
wichtig blühstreifen ränder zu haben
muss er sich auch geben ja haben wir
auch unter sich der führen und sehr sehr
weit so viele hatten wir noch nie wie
wir es jetzt haben in deutschland aber
dass wir diese flächen in krisenzeiten
wo wir wissen dass wir einen enormen
verlust an ernte haben werden weltweit
dass wir diese flächen in der gunst
region nicht nutzen um wirklich kaum zum
beispiel anzubauen um wirklich
nahrungsmittel anzubauen das ist aber
mittel dabei nicht alle diese flächen
oder nicht alle er ja überhaupt nicht
immer aber immer beispiel die einzigen
naturräume dies überhaupt noch hinein
aber natürlich dass wir sagte magath
nein nein also jetzt bleiben dann alles
nachgedacht es sind nicht die einzigen
an dafür da
sein sonst ich habe die gesetze mir
gemacht ich war deswegen sagten in der
wir haben die gemeinsame europäische
agrarpolitik die gab so grün war sie
noch nie so nachhaltig mit 4%
stilllegungsflächen das kann man sich in
friedenszeiten leisten und es geht darum
genauso wie herr mansur sagte mit für
immer sondern dass wir dort wo wir
engpässe haben diese kunst flächen das
heißt kunst region heißt ich muss wenig
reinstecken um eine gute ernte zu
bekommen dass sie dem äthiopischen
anders aus zum beispiel dass wir das
nutzen um dort wo wir wirklich ausfälle
haben die kompensieren zu können es geht
ums essen für menschen ich habe schon
alles das jetzt alles platt gemacht
werden nein ich hab das schon verstanden
aber es gibt natürlich auch eine
verknappung politik es geht jetzt nicht
nur um die ukraine wo dann wächst das
korn herkommt ich habe letztens ein
interview gesehen von dem bauer der mir
gesagt hat dass die preise durch
verknappung scon politik hoch geschoben
werden und das ist zum beispiel in
frankreich offensichtlich eine
organisation gibt die das mehl
kontrolliert oder die mehlpreise und
auch die ver.di also die die die
exportierende des mehls aber das
schreiben und die politik muss handeln
und ja ich habe viele projekte die wir
in der letzten jahren erlebt haben wo
wohlstand projekte
gehalten und ich glaube dass das was wir
in den nächsten monaten erleben wenn
viele menschen nicht mehr das leisten
was sie für das leben brauchen dass wir
wirklich ein instabiler gesellschaft
haben vor allem im bereich migration und
integration
die leute sind zufrieden aber in dem
moment wo sie unzufrieden sind wo sie
nicht das leisten was sie brauchen
werden wir unruhen erleben und das ist
hochgefährlich und ich frage mich warum
der kleiner mensch immer mitmacht bei
solchen preisen wasserleitungen es gibt
viele demokratische möglichkeiten
einfach auch ein protestzug star
außerdem demonstrieren nicht wer denkt
einfach ungenau oder außerdem ganz
nachdenken ganz einfach ich fange alle
nur das zu kaufen was man wirklich erste
naja und nicht so viel machen ich wollte
ich wollte gern zu der ursprungs these
zurück sie waren ja mal
landwirtschaftsministerin und kennen
sich das hat da sehr gut aus aus einer
gesundheitspolitik wir gemerkt haben was
würden sie denn jetzt konkret machen
wenn sie jetzt regieren würden zurück zu
ihrer these was würden sie sehr konkret
also wenn man gerade kurz bei den
nahrungsmittel bleiben ich würde dieses
instrument was die eu-kommission uns
ermöglicht auch als deutschland nutzen
genau laufen lässt auch für für
lebensmittelproduktion nutzen bei allen
übrigens weiterhin umweltauflagen die
gelten während ich lebensmittelanbau
zweiter punkt ist kalte progression
sofort anpassen das heißt sie kennen das
dass wir am ende auch bei einer
gehaltserhöhung ich nicht in eine höhere
steuerklasse kommen und nachher weniger
haare vorher ist es eine reform aber ich
wollte halt an dieser sache gemacht hat
auch was mit dem grundfreibetrag zu tun
aber nicht nur und dritter punkt ganz
klar der staat erhebt abgaben steuern
auf energie auf treibstoff auf wenn wir
heizen und diese abgaben sind im eu
vergleich enorm hoch und das ist eine
phase wo ich ganz klar sage hier
verdient der staat mit den steigenden
preisen mit und das kann nicht sein dass
das zulassen der bürger geht um dein
letztes das wundert mich dass die
sozialdemokraten darüber nicht sprechen
ist ein hartz4 empfänger dessen hat vier
gehaltene hieß jetzt mal bezog bezieht
sich auf den akten warenkorb der
berechnet wird aber der warenkorb müsste
jetzt mal angepasst werden weil auch ein
hartz4 empfänger dafür dass nicht mehr
bekommt und nummer so ein beispiel wenn
ich jetzt heute 100 euro habt kann was
für 100 euro kaufen in einem jahr habe
ich nur noch 94 euro und im zehn jahren
nur noch die hälfte mit diesen
lösungsvorschlägen und diesem aufruf
geben wenn eine ganz kurze
unterbrechungen sind gleich zurück bis
gleich
[Musik]
also da kann ich einen lauten und nicht
ernst nehmen als sogenannten experten
sogar meine damen und herren fehlte der
85 köpfen und meinungen von jeder von
uns hat ein thema mitgebracht was ihn
bewegt ärgert freut oder schockiert
[Musik]
so nicht privatjet buschi hergiswil
wetten
aber niemand von den politischen
parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen hier einfach nur freiheit diese
grünen roten der darin führen
hochtrabende debatten über die rettung
des weltklimas und um die füße russen
die ratten das thema ist viel zu wichtig
um es nur der ard zu überlassen lasst
den leuten spaß wir sehen da etwas was
eigentlich fatale ist in der politik bei
den journalisten deren job ist es doch
gerade abweichende meinungen zu finden
und sie sollen den doch auch richtig
dürfte sein
manko vielleicht einmal kurz daran
gehindert werden wir ganz nennen doch
das sind übliche anorak träger
ausdrücken ich hatte meinen beifahrer
meine sache immer bekommt er kümmert
sich darum niemand ist hier denn da ist
er ganz knapp drüber sprechen das ist
ein fakt nicht fertig richtig froh ist
die aufgabe von journalismus einfach die
verlautbarung der politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
und damit sind wir zurück stellen dass
sie dran geblieben sind und es geht
direkt weiter mit frauen neigen und
tesla
eigentlich mit grünheide genauso haben
wir wenig grün wesentlich wichtiger die
gewerkschaft anders hinaus also was mich
immens stört ist der ständige zuwachs in
den letzten jahren der verschmelzung von
konzernen und politik und zwar in einer
soll sichtbaren weise dass man manchmal
wirklich denkt ja wo sind da noch die
volks interessen die des einzelnen
bürgers weil man sich da so
zusammensetzt und dann miteinander deals
macht und dann gibt es da noch ein
interesse gibt es noch die world
economic forum wo sie dann noch
zusammensitzen und auch nicht
großkonzerne noch ein paar deals machen
und so weiter erneuert wie auch immer
verschwörungstheorien das ist keine
verschwörung auf keinen fall jeden sei
ich bin in der bürgerinitiative von
grünheide und habe hautnah miterlebt wie
das dann so abläuft in der praxis im
zusammenhang mit umweltschutz und
zusammen mit bürgerschutz auch also
bürgerrechte bei den öffentlich
laufenden verfahren in zusammenhang mit
diesem grünheider projekt also mit
dieser firma und ich habe dort dinge
erlebt die konnte ich gar nicht fassen
weil das ist es ist nicht sehr trockene
gegen das brandenburg und berlin haben
einfach große wasserprobleme schon viele
viele jahre liegt sicher auch an
sandboden liegt auch an der art und
weise der wald strukturen dass viele
nadelbäume sind aber dann muss man
natürlich dagegen steuern und es gab
sehr viele konzept in den letzten 20
jahren und plötzlich flogen die alle
einfach weg es wurde alles einmal
gekippt und es hieß der mann also in dem
fall ihre maske kommt ein gebiet ein
waldstück das direkt im
natura-2000-gebiet direkt nebendran
liegt das höchst geschütztes naturgebiet
und unten drunter gibt es ein
trinkwasserschutz körper und dieser
trinkwasserschutz körper und jetzt kommt
es dann
versorgt ich glaube 120.000 menschen der
gesamten region und ist sozusagen
zentrum einer einer jahr trinkwasser
ebene unterirdisch die in das berliner
urstromtal rhein fließt in die spree und
unter anderem auch berlin versorgt und
jetzt nimmt diese firma ich glaube ein
drittel der wasser einnahmen sich die
ein bürgerentscheid dafür gestimmt dass
die produktionsstätten dürfen ein
bürgerentscheid gab es nicht es gab
keinen fall also keinen bürgerentscheid
es gab stadtrat diskussion gab einen
bürgermeister ist extrem vorangetrieben
hat und es gab einen umweltminister und
einen wirtschaftsminister dort vor ort
und einen ministerpräsident der so das
habe ich selbst gelesen anweisungen ins
umweltministerium gegeben hat so viele
so viele dinge zu tun wie nur möglich um
vorab genehmigungen zu erteilen nachdem
emissionsschutz gesetz die haben bis
heute keine tatsächliche baugenehmigung
nur immissionsschutzgesetz klingen so
schnell alles vor abfahrt wie
normalerweise nur in china es stimme ihn
insofern zu will ihre these aufgreifen
von verschmelzen interessen zwischen
conti hat man sich in brandenburg gibt
es leider keine konzern deshalb
verschmelzen die hier dieser ganz
besonders mit der freundlich finde weil
hier ich will es ja nur erklären weil
hier geht es um 40.000 arbeitsplätze in
einer dürfte krems 10.000 herren so
gesagt und es sind im moment dreieinhalb
tage wurde aber es ist soll mal 40
werden ja irgendwie also jedenfalls
viele arbeitsplätze da hängen ja noch
menschen dran die das besonders
attraktiv machen die befragung nahm sie
der bürgerinitiative angehören er wird
welchen argumenten haben dann die
zuständigen behörden den hinweis auf den
verlust von grundwasser abgewehrt die
haben das überhaupt nicht abgewehrt also
soweit ich saß zwei wochen in dieser in
dieser anhörung und habe unter anderem
die bürger vertreten und wir haben
darauf hingewiesen es wird eine
naturkatastrophe auf uns zurollen die
jetzt schon da ist weil jetzt schon das
wasserwerk da drüben die neuzuzüge lang
und da kommen einige mit 102 liter pro
tag
rationiert jeder haushalt kriegt nur
noch 102 liter 165 liter sind der
normale durchschnitt für jeden haushalt
also da darf praktisch derjenige der
jetzt hinzuzieht nicht mal mehr seinen
rasen rosen wenn er drei kinder hat und
laden will kriegt der strafe weil es zu
viele das wird ja nicht stellt euch das
mal vor ich meine das ist im moment die
rationalisierte rationieren weil nicht
genug wasser da ist und diese firma ist
in der ersten ausbaustufe und hat jetzt
schon 1,3 millionen
kubikmeter und will noch zwei
ausbaustufen machen und will sich auch
nochmal 100 hektar wald holen obwohl es
165 sind sowie ausgerechnet wurde also
die wollen sich da aus brighton tatsache
ist dieses gebiet ist der falsche ort
und wir haben das in der anhörung immer
wieder gesagt es gibt andere orte in
hamburg auf jeden fall spielsweise der
lausitz zum beispiel da gibt es
industriebrachen noch ein 11 sie fordern
und es auf den punkt das dass sich
wieder als untersuchungsausschuss und
sie waren das geschlossen wird das land
würde das wenn man mich jetzt so fragt
würde ich sagen also arbeitsplätze jahr
auf jeden fall aber sie waren da
entstehen lassen wird in grünheide ich
halte es für den absolut falschen ort
und ich weiß dass es so oder so zur
katastrophe kommt wenn dir das
ignorieren und ich finde es erschreckend
was wir dort erlebt haben dass also das
dass das umweltamt kriegt offensichtlich
so wie ich gelesen habe anweisungen vom
ministerium und da wird ignoriert und
wenn sie dann von wasserknappheit reden
sagen sie die bösen bauern dürften nicht
so viel wasser rein aber tatsache ist
dass die leute jetzt schon probleme mit
wasser und es wird irgendwann auch
berlin treffen weil nämlich von dort
auch die wasserversorgung nach berlin
geht das ist ein riesenproblem ist das
ja da halten sich auch für den falschen
ort das kann ich überhaupt nicht
beurteilen um es mal ganz kurz zu sagen
aber eines kann ich auch sagen
wenn das ganze in china gebaut wird
können wir gar nichts kontrollieren uns
mal kurz zu sagen wir wollen dass eine
so genannte verkehrswende stattfindet
dass wir uns anders bewegen klar schön
wenn jeder irgendwie nv nutzt also
öffentlicher personennahverkehr den gibt
es nicht so sehr im ländlichen raum wir
wollen arbeitsplätze haben das heißt
sehr sehr häufig der osten wird
abgehängt wir haben keine arbeitsplätze
und dann sage ich schon sehr klar ja
wenn wir wir haben ja von tesla
gesprochen wenn wir jetzt
e-mobilität voranbringen wollen dann
muss es auch irgendwo gebaut werden das
ist so ähnlich wie mit den windrädern
und mit vielem anderen auch man ist
dafür das ist irgend eine wende gibt
aber bitte nicht vor meiner haustür und
ich kann das jetzt mit ich kann es weder
verifizieren noch falsifizieren aber
eine behörde kann nicht einfach dinge
türken ums ehrlich sozusagen eine
behörde kann nicht auch eine
umweltbehörde kann nicht einfach gesetze
und regeln ignorieren also ich kann
jetzt noch mal sagen als bürger muss ich
davon ausgehen dass das stimmt so lange
bis das gegenteil bewiesen ist und wenn
es ein untersuchungsausschuss gebe kann
man ja machen auf dem das spiel
werden aber ich glaube wir im landtag
gibt es jemanden der partei die sind
natürlich nicht beurteilen aber ich
hoffe dass es irgendwann mal einrichten
weil ich saß zwei wochen in diesem in
dieser anhörung und ich weiß genau was
da läuft und ich kann in den eins sagen
da wurde jedes rechtliches schlupfloch
genutzt um vor vorab jegliche art von
zulassung zuzulassen bestimmte sachen
sind bis heute nicht überprüft da sind
auch gelder die eigentlich für die
aufarbeitung von der ferne blase die
muster weg aus einem
trinkwasserschutzgebiet da ist eine drin
die ist hochgefährlich wenn die platz
ist das ganze trinkwasserschutzgebiet
vergiftet zwei millionen euro pro jahr
vom bund wurden ans land bezahlt sie
sind irgendwo hin geschlossen das ist
nicht repariert man muss doch ein am
lauten hier kann eine nirgendwohin
geflossen sind also dann können sie
mehrfachen untersucht das ist dann auch
was für die bild -zeitung sicherlich da
jemanden hinzuschicken zu recherchieren
also wenn gelder veruntreut werden vom
bund nicht so verwandt wird dann haben
wir ein ganz anderes thema und das ist
ja kein nein wir haben einen sobald sie
was meint herr nachtwei ein thema ist
nicht nur dass drei augen fünf rohren
geschlossen wurden und fünf männer ich
hatte wirklich den eindruck ich sitz vor
drei affen die so machen
ich störe mich daran dass man
unterschiedlich mit menschen umgeht also
eine mittelständische firma hätte diese
möglichkeiten es ist schwer es danach
aus als wenn sie nicht wären überall so
also ja wirklich meisten leuten die dort
wohnen ja wir das nicht verifizieren das
ist eine hauptwirkung frauen neigen sie
haben ja sicher wir haben ja vorher
china erwähnt ich will jetzt nicht eine
gegenthese haben aber ich finde es gut
wenn wir weniger bürokratisch arbeiten
ich finde es gut wenn sachen schnell
passieren in diesem land wir brauchen
arbeitsplätze
es geht um den wohlstand es geht um das
führende position in der welt und es
kann nicht sein und das ist nicht
irgendwie wirklich ich kenne mich da
nicht aus aber ich kann nicht sein dass
wir prioritäten setzen dass wohlstand
der allerletzte denn wir betrachten und
warten erst mal auf aber wenn man wasser
aber wir hätten schon recht wir hätten
schon gerne in china mit umweltschutz ja
absolut nicht unser euro ohne umwelt
und dann sagen wir stellen das auch
überhaupt nicht beurteilen was faul sagt
aber
natürlich können wir uns vorstellen dass
die behörden die augen zugemacht haben
weil der ministerpräsident gesagt hat
das wollen wir sagte ich halte das für
unser land wahnsinnig wichtig lasst mal
fünfe gerade sein
das wird schon irgendwo hinhauen
natürlich arbeiten behörden auch so sie
kommt aus der politik sie wissen doch
was alles durchgehen ist womöglich das
lka hatte ich meine
man so und du hin heide wird bestimmt
aufgearbeitet in erster instanz sollte
sein wo es ist nicht so einfach jetzt
von dem thema zum thema ehrenmord zu
gehen übrigens ein begriff der sehr
problematisiert in den letzten jahren
weil man gerne von zumiez spricht aber
wir haben den letzten zwei wochen zwei
frauen isra und schülern die auf
deutschem boden hier in deutschland
ermordet wurden weil sie emanzipiert
leben wollten weil sie von ihrem
selbstbestimmtes leben gebraucht machen
wollen und diese frauen nehmen wir oder
nehmen vor allem die neue feministischen
akteure in diesem land als
kollateralschaden sie wollen sich damit
nicht beschäftigen sie wollen von
phoenix sprechender trifft hier aller
kulturen aber die kulturellen religiösen
hintergründe solche daten übrigens da
sind nicht nur frauen betroffen sondern
auch männer auch homosexuelle männer
werden ermordet wenn sie in diesen
kulturelle homosexualität offen leben
das heißt passt filme mit licht und ich
frage mich warum sind wir nicht mehr in
der lage über bestimmte themen zu
sprechen und diese frauen komplett
vergriffen es gibt keine auf streit
keine debatten viele zeitungen haben
nicht mal darüber geschrieben ober
solchen phänomen ist
haben wir durchschnittlich übrigens die
statistik gibt es es gibt nur
ehrenamtler die so viele sammeln wir
reden von zehn bis zwölf frauen die
jedes jahr in deutschland ermordet
wurden frauen die nach deutschland
gekommen sind weil sie hier frei leben
sollen und sie haben oder sie sind hier
in deutschland ermordet wurden von ihren
familienmitgliedern und darüber redet
kleider und ich sage wer feministisch
sein will wer über frauenrechte reden
will darf nicht auf einem auge blind
sein muss und er da vor allen dingen
nicht glauben dass er für
gleichberechtigung sorgt wenn man für
gender sternchen doppelpunkt sich
verkämpft und auf die straße geht mir
auch briefe schreibt wenn ich nicht
verbraucherinnen sage und das heißt ich
sei gegen gegen frauenrechte was sind
totaler quatsch ist frauen dem nichts so
leben können wie sie wollen nicht leben
können und heiraten könnten beruf
ergreifen können wie sie wollen wenn sie
hier in unserem land leben die leiden
darunter dass wir tolerieren dass es
andere menschen und geschlechterbilder
gibt und warum trauen wir uns nicht weil
einem sofort entgegen gehalten wird das
sei zb islamophob dass er rassistisch
und ich habe das auch ich habe ein buch
geschrieben über das thema frauenrechte
dass integration niemals funktionieren
wird wenn frauenrechte nicht vollständig
auch eine aber wie kommt es denn das
sage ich ganz offen dass ich in der
illusion lebe dass es dieses problem in
der breite seit ein paar jahren in
deutschland nicht mehr gibt wir haben
früher intensiv über solche ehren so
genannten so in der mord diskutiert da
kannten wir alle die namen der
umgebrachten frauen und jetzt die die
sie erwähnen kennen wir nicht dass ich
das liegt am ende ich will nur ich
wollte fragen spielt ich will von mir
aus gerne ich will nur eine frage
anschließen
das liegt sicher zum teil auch in den
medien die von den morden erfahren aber
nicht über berichten oder nur kleinen
drüber berichten erscheinen aber gibt es
nach ihrer kenntnis
genug
anlaufstellen für frauen aus solchen
familien die sich bedroht fühlen und die
ahnen dass in irgendwas passiert gibt es
spezielle beratungsstellen für
muslimische frauen gibt es aber kaum
wissen sie ich habe zwei jahre bei lka
gearbeitet genau als berater zu solchen
themen vor mir klassen über 100 frauen
die solche gefahren gehabt taten gehabt
haben und wir haben versucht wirklich
diese frauen zu helfen es ist nicht
immer möglich auch die bürokratie spielt
hier eine rolle es kommt darauf an ob
man in berlin bei ein lka-beamter
ankommt der sich auskennt mit dem thema
oder jemand der diese frau zurück in
ihre familie geschickt weil er es nicht
versteht welche dimensionen richtig
seriös und christen es muslimische
frauen sein die die muslimischen frauen
patenmodell de mission lka beamter es
gibt auch lka-beamter die muslime sind
die sich ausgaben und unerklärlich
ausgepowerten herauf vielleicht nicht
das braucht ihre männer finden nicht die
der richtige ansprechpartner in solchen
sachen aber sie haben ja eine frage
gestellt vorher wo sind die medien warum
ist das jetzt mittlerweile politisch
inkorrekt ober solche thema ansprechen
warum reden wir um nicht mehr über
integration und dazu gehört natürlich
auch die sexuelle selbstbestimmung ich
sage ich bin erstmal angekommen in
deutschland wenn ich begreife dass eines
selbstbestimmtes leben für meine tochter
keine risiko für mich und meine familie
sondern eine bereicherung und da haben
wir unfassbare nachholbedarf wir sind
nicht da wir reden mittlerweile von
teilhabe weil dadurch die mehrheit
gesellschaft in der verantwortung
gezogen wird aber über die minderheiten
darf man in eine progressive politisch
korrekte orientierter gesellschaft nicht
mehr sprechen und sie waren diejenige
der damals auch ein kritik an die
talkshows gehalten haben dass sie zu
viel über den islam sprechen cavalli
haben als sie ihm kriminalisiert haben
ich kann nicht herüber und bin hier
einen muslim und ich schwarz diese
talkshows es geht um den islamismus es
geht um solche phänomene
darum ging es den himmel ragen hier ging
es darum dass man keine angst verbreitet
vor syrern und anderen will muslime die
nach deutschland sondern dass man sie
aufnimmt aber es war eigentlich stehe
geht es eigentlich darum dass man eben
diese sehr kulturellen
widerspreche also da es gibt einfach
dinge die kulturell völlig
unterschiedlich sind in deutschland und
man darf das nicht tolerieren
zum beispiel das sein gutes schlusswort
man darf das nicht tolerieren wir sind
nämlich schon am ende der sendung
angekommen ich bedanke mich herzlich bei
meinen gästen wenn sie mögen morgen
abend sind wir wieder für sie da
[Musik]